okay well the health secretary has said
the uk must be very cautious about this
new variant of coronavirus that emerged
in southern africa while the eu has made
its fears clear too but what makes it so
concerning and what should we be doing
about it well here to answer some of
your questions that you've sent in to us
and some of mine is edinburgh university
epidemiologist professor roland cowell
an immunization lead for the royal
college of gp's dr george casianos thank
you very much indeed for joining us um
if i can come to you first uh dr cao
we've got a question from um
norman who's in south africa actually i
believe he's saying if the new variant
has been detected in israel and hong
kong too
why have only southern african countries
been put on the red list
um it is a really good question and it's
an important one because it obviously as
the variant spreads broader we need to
cast our network broader in terms of
what we consider to be at risk now
initially south africa had by far the
highest number of cases it's the most
natural place to which to be concerned
about um but now we see it spreading
more broadly we really should be
considering uh restrictions that are
similarly broadly uh imposed
okay um i've got a question for both of
you now uh actually i was wondering if
um pcr tests now that the in the uk
we're favoring lateral flow tests
instead of pcr tests is that a concern
of identifying
this variant and other variants and and
to that point uh nikki has asked us um
if uh
if this variant doesn't evade vaccines
one will come along eventually do we
think we should reintroduce pcrs for
arrivals to the uk i'll put it to both
of you we haven't heard from dr
cassiano's yet so i'll come to you first
thank you well nick is is raising a very
important question there of course a pcr
can be done in before they come to the
uk but we cannot sequence that pcr we
can only sequence pcrs that are done
here in the uk see it could be uh
arrival you can combine both if you like
but basically even if we
do pcrs on arrival
they are not all sequence
on the other hand when you have got a
problem like the one we possibly have
now it is possible that all pcrs from
targeted countries will be
really sequenced but don't forget that
we have got the red list whereby
the traveler
is going to be managed in a quarantine
hotel but
they have a pcr 72 hours before they
arrive in the uk but also two pcrs here
in the uk on day two and on day eight
and those
almost certainly will be sequenced from
countries that may may harbor the news
variant yeah uh professor cao what what
do you make of that because actually it
doesn't cover all countries does it pcr
tests
uh
indeed i mean i think one of the things
to keep in mind is that we have two
different kinds of problems the first
one is that what do we do now now at
this point we really do want to be
detecting any of this variant that might
be coming into the country and making
sure that you know we're aware of where
the risks are coming from so pcr tests
definitely now sequencing obviously is
the most precise thing we can do but
even the pcr test itself the the genes
that it detects we're fortunate that in
this case this variant uh has one of
them uh a variation is in one of the
things we detect even without sequencing
the other question is what do we do
outside of this now
variants show up all the time so slight
changes in the virus and so we really
need to know as we're doing that
sequencing um whether or not we're
interested in those changes so it's only
really useful if we know that there are
variants of interest or variance of
concern that we need to be tracking
otherwise the extra information actually
isn't helping us that much
that's really interesting okay we have
another question for you both from uh
john i believe and uh john's asking um
would it be sensible for the government
to reimpose mandatory face coverings at
the very least in crowded indoor spaces
or large outdoor gatherings let's stay
with you professor cal first and then
we'll go to dr cassianis
yes
you know i obviously live in scotland in
scotland we have the mandatory mass
squaring in indoor spaces um they
certainly the evidence is that they can
help with transmission now remember a
key point right now is we're heading
into the winter we are very very on edge
with regards not just with covet but
other respiratory infections anything we
can do to keep cases down now will put
us in a better place to combat things
especially if this variant turns out to
be a variant of concern dr casianos
the advisors of the government will
advise the government and they will take
a decision and currently we all know in
england that decision has not been taken
but as citizens we have a responsibility
and i think that the first
responsibility is that we ensure that we
are vaccinated so
if you have not been vaccinated please
go ahead and get vaccinated if you only
had one dose of the vaccine please go
and get your second dose when it's time
for it and if you are eligible for a
booster do have your booster because
it's very important to have really good
immunity for anything that might happen
in the future the second thing is that
we have a we need to take personal
responsibility as regards to personal
protection measures and here
a well-fitting mask that is used now we
know that mass can reduce uh the um risk
of of catching the infection by at least
half 53
is wonderful
hand washing frequently ensuring that
there is good ventilation in the room
where we are with others and of course
always keeping our distance from others
so we're not too near when they're
actually speaking to us so these are
basic measures that we need to take
vaccination and personal protection
measures yeah going back to those uh
foundational basics and you're putting
your thumb up there aren't you um
professor cao so to the point of
vaccines jeff has a question he's asking
do the variance mutations
mean some types of vaccines will be more
effective against it than others
professor cal
um i i think this is more a question for
for other calling but broadly speaking
we knew there's a variation in the
efficacy of vaccines across different
variants the concern about this
particular one is there's so many
mutations on the spike proteins that
there's a reasonable chance that none of
the vaccines will be particularly
effective against it
okay dr cassianos
well this new variant has about 28 to 32
mutations spread over the whole spike
over more than four antigenic sites so
we don't know our antibodies from our
vaccines and from previous infection
whether they will be able to mobilize
all those areas there maybe
it's quite possible that our vaccines
will partly work we just don't know we
need to wait for the virus in the
laboratory to be challenged with
antibodies from us and see whether
we we can actually kill the virus
whether around the business can kill the
virus
yeah understood dr gaziano's professor
cal thanks very much indeed
you're welcome